hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always is Alex muellering and I'm
excited to be talking with you today
about positional pros and cons
essentially we're going to look at uh
I've done some lectures on how to make
good plans but in order to do that we
really have to first understand and
account for the pros and cons of Any
Given position right both for your side
and your opponents you can think of this
in other terms you could use strengths
and weaknesses advantages and
disadvantages whatever you like but
basically we're going to say if we look
at any given position how do we analyze
it to figure out in what ways is my side
better in what ways is my opponent's
side better and worse for each and so on
and so forth
and then use that information to make a
solid plan
there's really a few there's just a
couple of things that we're going to be
looking out for tonight we're going to
try and focus on these the first and
most important is King safety
right the the goal of the game is
getting the king so we're going to talk
about that a lot we're going to look at
Material another really important one
how many pieces does each side have and
what are they all worth
we're going to look at peace activity so
not just what pieces do you have but
especially how are you using them where
are they placed
we're going to look at time or Tempo a
little bit and I'll ex that was a little
more complex but we'll get to it when we
get to it as well as space right how
much of the chessboard you control and
finally if we have any time left at the
end we'll look at the spawn structures
and how that informs the position we
might not get to that but we'll just
have to see the other thing that's going
to be kind of a through line for all of
these is to take a try and notice which
of these advantages are short-term and
which are long term whether they're
advantages or weaknesses right which
ones are more long-term or permanent
parts of the position and which ones are
more temporary and easily changeable
okay with that said let's jump into it
our first one here is King safety it's
the most important advantage and one of
the first things I look out for with
this with kind of beginner players is
really hammering in this idea of
castleing early and castling often so
castling as we know once the pieces are
out of the way of the king whichever way
we're going we Slide the king towards
the rook and this is important for a lot
of reasons right especially in the
opening if we leave our King out in the
center
it can become a target for a lot of
attacks in different ways so here's one
example this is something I've seen
countless times and lots of variations
in games I have played and watched
to something like this we're going to
play some very standard moves put some
Pawns in the center put some pieces
attacking those Pawns
and we have here a scotch game with D4
not really waiting to try and set this
move up instead allowing black to
capture
and the scotch Gambit not recapturing
this pawn and what white is doing is
saying I'm going to prioritize the
activity of my pieces over getting this
one Pawn back I'm probably going to be
able to win it back later so that's not
my priority here
and one example of this is let's say
black gets really greedy says okay I've
already got one Pawn
what if I try and go for this other Pawn
here maybe something like Queen to E7
again this is an idea I've seen a lot
white here castles and we notice white
is not really caring as much about
material material is very important but
King safety is more important black has
spent too much time trying to get a lot
of material and in the end it's really
going to cost the right move here for
white of course being Rook to E1 pinning
the queen to the king because we are
castled our King is safe and our Rook is
in position to get involved in the game
and because black is not castled in this
particular position that plus them
getting their Queen a little bit too
aggressive
they are now vulnerable even though
there's no Checkmate threats right uh
they're still losing the game most
likely because this queen is now going
to have to be traded for this Rook
another way this could have played out
right is let's say instead they play
Knight to F6 not getting the queen out
but still a little material hungry
white again can castle and let's say
black says okay I'm going to take this
Pawn now theoretically this is fine for
black it's practically maybe kind of
scary there's a lot of danger for black
here because they've focused again on
the material and not so much on getting
their King safe and so this can sort of
be punished there's a few different ways
one of the classics is called the
Anderson attack
where white again plays rookie one
capitalizing on the fact that this King
has not castle that's still sitting out
in the open
and this Knight is now unprotected
unable to run away because it's pinned
we would hit the king and uh a big
Target
black can do a lot of different moves to
try and save this one of the most common
and probably the best is Pawn to D5
looking to again fight in the center
here attack our Bishop defend this pawn
and this move looks like it holds
everything together but because of some
kind of fun tricks in this position
if you want to try and solve this at
home feel free to pause and take a look
but there's a lot of material so we're
not going to pause and spend too much
time on it this is more just for
demonstration but white actually has
this really beautiful move Bishop takes
D5
because now after the queen takes back
Knight to C3 and you cannot take this
Knight the Knight is pinned to the king
and if you take with the pawn you lose
your queen
so white is going to pick this piece
back up and if black is not careful
if they're still not paying attention to
their King
then maybe something like this to attack
the Knight white can actually end this
game in one move with Knight to F6
double check
mate
really really brutal and all of this is
because of a few reasons but the one
we're looking at right now is just that
White's King was safe and Black's King
was not King safety and castling early
another example or kind of iteration of
that is to notice that not all of these
opening pawns are equal
the two f-pawns white F Pawn and blacks
F Pawn in the starting position are
weaker than any other Pawn on the board
and the reasoning for that is because
they are the only pawns that are just
defended by the King right every other
Pawn has some other piece defending it
sometimes multiple pieces right but the
F pawns are only defended by the king
because of that they are big targets
right something like the scholars mate
is going to try and attack those pawns
but they can also
be problems if you kind of intentionally
weaken those squares so one way to do
that is to move these pawns out of the
way in this position black thinks oops
and black thinks well you've attacked my
Pawn with your knight
so I'm just going to defend it there's
maybe a night move or a pawn move these
would be much better but here F6 looks
like they're defending looks to be no
problem but the issue is this king is
now very weak right there's now an
opening to attack so you want to avoid
making weakening moves that expose your
king to Danger give your opponent the
chance to attack them this is really
going to mitigate King safety so anytime
a king is unsafe in the position it's a
big positional weakness for them or if
it's your king it's a personal weakness
for you and vice versa so in this
position the best move for white most
likely is actually to sacrifice this
Knight on E5 because this Pawn is not
really able to recapture it
backs Black's best move is probably to
just play something like Queen to E7 and
even then it's not going to be very
pretty but if they try and take the
Knight then again because this king is
exposed on this weak diagonal Queen to
H5 comes with check and black is either
losing a rook if they play something
like G6 to block we can now take attack
their King and attack the rook and we
will pick up that Rook
or they can try and save their King but
this in the end will cost them the game
check check black does have one more
chance to survive here if they play the
move Pawn to D5 a lot of people don't
play this move because they think I mean
you're just going to take it and nothing
has changed the importance with that
move is actually that this bishop now
becomes a crucial defender of the black
king so knowing how to open up your
pieces and get your pieces active as
we'll talk about later can be really
important but if they don't do that move
and just keep running the king away
eventually they will get chased into a
corner
where Checkmate will be inevitable
so
you want to Castle your king early to
get it safe away from this weak square
right one of the benefits When You
Castle is notice that the Rook slides
over to the f file and defends that weak
Pawn so that's one reason we want to
Castle we want to keep our King out of
Harm's Way but you also want to make
sure you avoid just weakening your king
voluntarily by opening up this kind of
weak F Square
and obviously you can weaken other
squares later in the game but you want
to keep an eye on that
another example here of King safety is
this is more on the aggressive side is
when you are looking to find an
advantage in a position
you want to try and clear a path to the
King right just as we don't want to
weaken our own King we want to try and
expose our opponents and one of the best
way to do that is to try and eliminate
the Pawns in front of the king
so for example
if we look at some game like this again
E4 E5 Knight to F3 attacking our pawn
and this time we're not going to play F6
we're going to play Knight to C6
defending and let's just say white goes
for a very nice and normal Italian game
a lot of variations can happen here but
let's say White's taken our advice and
decides to Castle early in Castle often
and black notices that maybe we
shouldn't be taking some of these pawns
when our King is still out in the center
right maybe if we take we get some
dangerous exposed King ideas so instead
Black's going to go for this really
interesting move here Knight to G4 and
this is going to lead into kind of a
trap a famous One known as the fishing
pole where our goal here is to expose
this King create an advantage for us by
moving uh trying to remove some of these
pawns from being guards of the king
while they're in front of the king it's
really hard to attack him
in this position part of the weirdness
of this move is it moves a piece we've
already moved right normally you're
going to want to get other pieces new
ones into the game so we've already
moved this Knight twice that's a little
weird and White's thinking well it's a
little close to my king so maybe I don't
want it to stay there I'm going to play
a move very natural like H3 attack this
Knight and try and make it move another
time and just waste so much time that
white is doing great but the problem
here is black now plays the move Pawn to
H5
again we're going to talk about material
in a moment and a lot of people think
the material is the most important thing
when you're analyzing a position right
who has more pieces but this is to show
you that that's not always the case
right the most important thing in any
position is King safety because if
there's a way to get to the king it
doesn't matter what I've given up this
is why sacrifices are really really
popular
well if white decides to be greedy right
probably the best move for white is to
just ignore this and do some other move
you know maybe try and defend the center
develop a piece but if white says well
you've given me a knight I will take it
there is now a problem because we have
opened up the Kink where we've gotten
rid of this pawn and by capturing with
our Pawn
the main thing we're trying to do is
activate our pieces now our Rook is
looking down at blight's King
okay well there's a few problems so the
immediate one is this Pawn is attacking
this Knight and if you try and save it
say you play something like Knight to H2
but you could do any other move
now black jumps in with an attack Queen
to H4 linking with the rook and lining
up for a checkmate
this is pretty unfortunate if you're
white right even though black has given
up some material we were able to remove
some of these pawns from guarding the
king
so white doesn't really have any good
moves here if you just move the Knight
somewhere then the queen comes down with
a checkmate
so probably you have to try and move
like Pawn to F3 give your king a little
bit of breathing room to maybe try an
escape
but we don't want the king to Escape
right material taking something is not
as important as king safety so even
though we could take this Knight with
track and force the king away
we would rather keep the king locked
down in this position a beautiful
crushing move is Pawn to G3 controlling
the Escape square and making it so our
next move is going to be Checkmate uh
most likely the only way now white can
try and avoid this is to again try and
make room for the king to run so maybe a
move like Rook to E1 opening up a square
for the king to escape one more time
and here we can now take the Knight with
check
but we don't want the king to escape all
the way right even though black is doing
very well if we just say play Queen here
check the king can still run and the
king is going to survive a little bit
longer right we don't really want this
to happen so once again we're only going
to say how can we cut off the Escape for
the king and a really beautiful move in
this position noticing that we control
this Square this Pawn is guarding the
king here so he can't step that way so
the only Square we need to cover
is this one
E2 and we actually have one piece that
can cover E2 right now our Knight by
jumping to D4
the king now has nothing they can do and
no matter what move white plays the game
is over the king is just not safe enough
because we were able to make a materials
strategic sacrifice and open up room
to attack the king
another example here of King safety is
again recognizing that sometimes you can
sacrifice material yes question yeah for
sure
yes
foreign
but like for example trying to secure
the pawn on e4 before it
impossible to perform this so if we try
and take here for example
G3
yeah after that I still can perform the
same idea yeah so
yeah this would not perfectly transpose
right there's one more move added in and
the only way this works is if they
volunteer right so one they have to
Castle and two
um they would have to like try and
provoke and then trade
so like for example say here we could
play some other move or we could play H5
already kind of preemptively this might
be showing your hand a little bit
um and if white goes for it then yeah we
can just ignore that and continue to do
our own thing if we would like
uh but yeah they'll have more chances to
deviate but they're certainly welcome to
come back into this variation
for example we might open up this
morning like this scheme so for example
for example they may in the in the
original kind of way yeah
so for example after that they are like
for example playing page three then
for example now they are like in the
completely neglecting of how we are
refusing taking the
night is it like a quest for correct
it's not terrible so like yeah probably
what white needs to do here is go for
the center so D3 is probably fine or
maybe C3 to play for D4 or again like
Knight to C3 and black isn't like in any
danger probably the only downside is now
the question is okay well why did we
waste all this time moving the night
around
um and you can maybe try and continue
some attack with either like a pawn
storm or maybe even try and get the
queen but as long as our pawns are in
the way it's actually a little more
problematic so like this isn't bad it's
like
not great but it's mostly this is again
what we would call like a short-term
Advantage right there's some Tempo lost
but no material so as long as you're
okay and you end up developing your
pieces and finding somewhere to get your
king safe it would be fine
um so again with this idea of King
safety material is not the number one
thing so in this position I'll actually
give you a little bit of time oh Joshua
thank you for that sorry uh I will be
more
cognizant of giving the questions
basically we were just looking at this
variation and considering Alternatives
um and yeah saying could white choose
not to do this what would be White's
best option otherwise so like if they
don't go for this what is black in too
much trouble and the answer is not so
much it's not great but it's not the end
of the world
okay so in this position I'll actually
give you all a chance to try and solve
it here it's white to move and we can
notice that white has definitely made
some sacrifices right if we just count
the material we'll notice that white is
down significantly we have two knights
and a queen and some pawns versus two
Bishops two Rooks and a queen so at the
very least we're down two Rooks not so
good but because of King safety right
the number one thing we can actually
find a way to force uh force a win here
any ideas for what white should do here
this is tricky well I should do to try
and
claim a win due to Black's lack of
King's safety
all right chesteroid in the chat has the
idea Queen H6 this makes sense right and
whenever we're trying to get a checkmate
you want to control the space near our
opponent's king and we notice our Knight
is guarding this H6 Square so we can
bring our Queen in for check the king
now only has one move because we control
all of these squares so the King has to
go to G8
this is probably the hardest one to find
but what's what I would recommend
noticing is what squares our piece is
currently control right so our Queen
controls every square around this King
except one which is this Square
and noticing that we can maybe start to
look at our forcing moves and consider
some possibilities
I chest right again with a really nice
idea here Queen to h8 sacrificing the
Knight we want to look at what we're
controlling so with this move our Queen
is safe but we control the entire back
rank the H file and we control G7 and F6
which means once the King has captured
our Knight there will only be two
squares unaccounted for the square it's
on
and G6
and we have a way to deal with both of
these squares in one move we can play
the beautiful move Knight to E5 forking
the king in The Rook but more
importantly covering every Escape Square
for this king and you cannot block a
knight so this is checkmate
one final example here and then we're
going to switch to material
when you are going on some attack you
notice your opponent's king is maybe
weak or exposed but it's not somewhere
you can immediately Checkmate it
um a very common strategy is to find a
way to draw the king out into the open
usually with some series of forcing
moves like checks or something like that
and this is a really really pretty
example of that from a game
um
from I think like the early 1900s
but it's really really pretty so white
plays E4 black plays E5 Knight to F3 D6
defending the pawn this is the
Philadelphia defense
why Place Bishop to C4
Bishop to E7 so far all normal right
both sides are fighting for the center
looking to develop their pieces take
Stakes Knight to F6 Knight to C3
and both sides Castle
again nothing too unusual here and
there's going to be one strange move we
play H3 preventing a piece maybe jumping
into this Square annoyingly
Rook to E8
and Rook to E1 both the kings are fairly
safe the pieces are fairly developed and
here black plays a very it doesn't look
bad on first glance but it is a little
unusual black plays this move Knight to
D7
and this move doesn't look so bad
perhaps Black's plan is to reroute the
Knight to uh maybe G B6 and attack our
Bishop on C4 maybe they're even looking
to play to C5 and put pressure on our
Pawn on e4 a few different things this
Knight could be doing
but the problem here is not so obvious
there's a the main one is this yeah this
bishop now doesn't have a chance to get
developed normally you want to develop
your pieces first and we also notice
that this queen is pretty stuck right
can't really do anything for a move or
two now this will touch on later when we
get to Tempo if we have time but a move
like this right a weird piece move is
usually not such a big problem because
the only way we can capitalize on it is
if we play very quickly right if we give
black any time to breathe I'll just play
this move and life is normal
but in this position white found a
brilliant move that ends the game more
or less in a few moves
and does so by noticing okay well
there's two problems black has one this
King looks pretty
safe but we actually have potentially a
way to lure it out
and two this queen is fully trapped
there's it's stuck behind its own pieces
and there's really nothing that can be
done
so when you look here a move that jumps
out to me would be I would love to play
a move like Knight to E6 try and trap
the queen but the problem with that move
is there's a pawn guarding the square
however we can circumvent that if we're
very careful by first eliminating the
pawn this does two things Bishop takes
F7 check we sacrifice and now our plan
is
well if the king doesn't take we just
win a rook or we can play Knight to E6
and win the queen so the king is forced
to take
and now a few different people have
different ideas some people like Queen
to F3 or queen to H5 but the crushing
beautiful move found in the game here is
to play Knight to E6 anyway
because now if you don't take my knight
your queen is dead but if you take it we
have successfully drawn the king out
into out of hiding into the open and can
finish the game
with track
mates
really beautiful so the number one thing
in any position that's going to
determine uh what your plan is how to
make it and what advantages or
disadvantages you have is the king
safety looking out for your own King
keeping him safe and looking for ways to
expose your opponent's king or
capitalize on an already weakened King
okay the next uh kind of character of a
position the element of a position that
we want to look at is material
and usually this is actually the best
starting place for analysis right
because um not every position is going
to have some forcing Checkmate and
material is pretty easy to do right we
just look at what's on the board and
kind of calculate okay how many points
do they have for those who aren't aware
generally we say that a pawn is worth
about one point Knights and Bishops are
both worth about three points Rooks
about five the queen about nine the king
is infinite because you can never like
trade the king
so that's kind of our general analysis
and something that's really easy to do
in a game because some people say I well
I don't want to count and do a lot of
math and add it takes time is you can
just do an elimination right you can say
okay if any given position both sides
have two Rooks we can eliminate all the
Rooks we don't have to add any math they
both have four nights we don't have to
do anything like that and you can kind
of figure it out just what's left
so material is the first thing we want
to look at and I want to again
re-emphasize just the material is not
the most important thing it's maybe the
a good first step right just to get a
sense of the position but the most
important thing is King safety and to
illustrate that a little bit I have two
final examples for that first one is
ridiculous it's this position
it is white to move
and black has a according to leeches
369 Point material advantage
not so good if it were possible there's
a lot of Queens on this board and if
given the chance if black could make a
move any one of them could find some
Checkmate uh if you take this Pawn with
any of these five Queens then you win
but it is white to move and white has
one beautiful move does anyone see what
move white should play in this position
yeah spawn to A8
Rook you could also get a queen but I
like getting to a rook because it's even
less material we don't need it right the
king is just stuck right this is a
classic back rank obviously maybe not so
classic with what's on the board but
this is just to demonstrate that wall
material is important King safety is
always the most important
here's a more reasonable example of that
same kind of thing
in this position it is white to move and
if we just look at the material then we
might say okay let's let's take a look
we have one two three four five pawns
one two three four five pawns pawns are
equal Bishop Bishop night night Queens
Rooks it's all equal material is totally
equal it's an equal position so now we
need to look a little deeper
we can look at King safety right that's
kind of the most important thing
and maybe we notice okay our King is
okay for the moment but there's a lot of
pieces kind of aimed at our King I don't
love that our Queen and uh King are
lined up maybe this bishop one day will
try and come in we have a rook here now
but this looks a little dangerous
and then we look at White's King and say
okay well whites King isn't doing so
well either right our Bishop is covering
a lot of space and it actually has very
few places it can go
so uh neither King is doing so great but
black has the advantage of getting to
move first in this position so does
anyone see what move black should play
here not so easy but this is a really
fun one
uh
here
E4 yes and to Captain ketchup in the
chat as well uh Queen to E4 taking the
bishop
sacrificing the queen wait what we're
going to give up the queen
but white can't actually take it back
because again their king is not safe
we control too many squares
Rook to D1 and this is a back rank or an
opera mate uh in a picturesque way right
there is nothing white can do here we
control all of these squares except to
block with the Rook but because we
control it we take with our rook and the
king is fully trapped check mate
so again material is important but King
safety comes first because it allows us
to find nice tactical opportunities
but now let's give material its two
because it is very important as well in
understanding the advantages and
disadvantages the pros and cons of most
positions
one thing to note is that while
preserving your own material or sorry
that preserving your own material is
basically as important as trying to win
your opponents right if you're just
giving stuff away it doesn't matter if
you're tactically winning some beautiful
stuff you're going to lose it all so we
wanted to be aware of what our opponents
are attacking right so say something
like this a lot of people complain to me
about early Queen attacks they don't
know what to do when their opponent
brings their Queen up so early and I
understand the queen is a scary piece it
attacks a lot of the board
but the thing I always come back to is
to say what is the threat right and so
when we look at our material we want to
keep our material safe whenever you see
a queen just notice it's attacking a lot
of squares let's figure out what those
are and what the problems are
this queen here on H5 a lot of people
will immediately notice wait a minute
I've seen this before this is like a
Scholars mate I know what you're trying
to do right you're going to attack this
pawn and I'm gonna be dead so I need to
do something about that pawn and so a
lot of people will play a move like G6
blocking the queen and say haha I'm safe
unfortunately you weren't really paying
too much attention because this Pawn
wallet is a weak Pawn
is defended right our King does defend
it so you need to put more pressure on
it than just one piece
the real threat here is not this pawn
and it's not this one on the H file
because our Rook defends that it's E5
right our King is nothing is defending
this Pawn if you take it it's a check so
if we play a move like G6 Queen takes E5
check and you win The Rook
not so good
so when we stop and say okay what is the
threat we can identify how do we protect
our material right a good defense is
just as important as a good offense and
so here a move I would probably play
something looks very reasonable
something like Knight to C6 defending
if white continues their attack right
something like Bishop C4 again we say
what's the threat well the Queen's
threatening everything it was but now
the bishop has added an attacker okay
now we have to deal with this now if we
say okay well I'm not too worried and
play a move like Knight F6 we're getting
checkmated
so here something like G6 getting the
queen to no longer attack our Pawn is
good and if they go back once again we
say what is the threat whenever a queen
moves it attacks a lot of squares in
this case the only ones that really seem
to matter for us
it's actually just this one again right
they've relocated and renewed this
attack and so we have options we could
maybe defend but I don't want to block
this bishop so maybe just to move like
Knight to F6 and you get the idea right
we can continue to look for these
threats and how do we protect our
material because that's a very important
part of this uh this game
something else to keep in mind is
especially early in the game but this is
true later on you want to be suspicious
when your opponent just gives you
something for free right very rarely is
there a free lunch now sometimes they've
made a mistake and missed a move but
when you think you smell something a
little fishy you might want to take a
second look
in uh this is a really famous example of
that in the Queen's Gambit and the
climbed
where we notice a big part of this
opening for those less familiar is a lot
of pressure against these two pawns
right if black ever takes most likely
they're going to lose this Pawn later to
this bishop and if white ever takes then
maybe they're just helping black out by
opening up their Bishop so it's just a
lot of tension nobody really wants to
take here
but there is a lot of pressure
so we have now won two pieces attacking
D5 and black has one two three pieces
defending the square and white plays a
very reasonable move let's get our
Bishop out maybe bishop to G5 pinning
this Knight
and in this position I've had it a few
times one of my favorite moves to play
is knight from B to D7
because it looks so strange I'm blocking
in this bishop I'm defending my knight
yes but I'm actually like it's still
pinned and now my queen doesn't defend
this Pawn anymore so really it looks
like what I've done is I've gone from
having three Defenders on D5 to having
just one right because I can't take with
this Knight or I'll lose my queen and I
can't take with my queen because it's
blocked
and if white sees this and gets a little
greedy and says okay well let's trade
and you can't take this back so I'm
going to put some pressure on you
well
again we want to go back to material and
King safety if if somebody offers you
something be a little bit nervous
anyone know the best move for black in
this position
uh here
Knight to E4 is a really funny move I
like the idea
yeah so this is
um
there's like a variation of this that
I've seen for white
um the name is escaping me for now where
you put the Knight here and you control
all of these squares and then you do
some Checkmate
um we're not quite set up for that but
it is really close I would do something
very similar though and for those who
don't see the idea that's really nice we
would like to kind of force this King to
have to either be checkmated or give
something up but the problem is we would
like to play Bishop check but there's a
few things in the way one this bishop
can block two this Knight can capture
and we can deal with both of those in
one move
we take on D5 because now if you take my
queen
I check and I'm still winning if this
Knight was here the difference is I'm
not losing this bishop but I'm also not
getting this Knight so that probably
also works it's maybe just not as like
technically thorough because I'm not
simplifying the material but the idea is
the same white here has only one move
it's a block and we can trade
and we take and the only thing that's
changed right if we count the material
again only notice one two three four
five six one two three four five six
seven whites up a pawn
but two Rooks equal a knight and a
bishop equal we have an extra Knight so
it's basically a knight for a pawn uh
this is called the elephant trap it's
really really fun I have used this I
think in one real game not in a
tournament game but in a casual game I
usually don't play this opening in
tournament games but it's it does work
some people do fall for it because it's
not so obvious to see
um and so yeah essentially just be
careful because people will try and
trick and trap you yes
so basically what is the best idea so
for example for beginners I think all
the steps usually kind of dependent on
some different debuts right and is it
like in the winter to try to I don't
know all of them each time but somewhere
for example if I'm like playing on the
chest should I like start trying to kind
of teach someone to kind of better
memorize this uh traps so yeah the
question if I understand is how what
should be a beginner's approach to like
dealing with these traps like do you
just memorize all the trappy lines or
how do you avoid them
um my answer would be just I would start
one if you notice you're falling for a
mistake and you notice like the same
thing happened multiple times it's
always a good time to do some game
analysis just look back and say okay
what did I do how did this go wrong
um and if you're looking at a trap like
early enough often using an engine or
using just like an opening database can
give you some information of oh a lot of
people have fallen for this it's really
obvious what am I missing that they need
to look at I wouldn't necessarily say to
memorize stuff unless you notice you're
running into the same problem over and
over again but otherwise just generally
when
when you feel like you only have one
option or you feel like this seems like
I'm getting too much like it seems too
good to be true just giving me something
for free take a second look and
especially look at those forcing moves
right where can my opponent check my
king uh where can my opponent attack my
pieces especially that aren't defended
and it'll start to give you a better
sense it's not a perfect method but
those would be how I would start
uh here's another material advantage
question
is when you're thinking about material
right it's usually gained through some
kind of tactic so always being aware of
your tactics and we've done a few
different lessons on forcing moves and
tactical signals but here's just one
kind of basic fun example here
E4 E6 D4 D5 we have a French defense and
E5 the advanced and black immediately
goes for C5 right trying to fight
against this Pawn chain
C3 defending Knight C6 Bishop to B5 sort
of similar to last time right we have
some Knights that are involved in some
attacks and a bishop has come in to pin
the Knight
in this case game continues with Bishop
to D7 on pinning and Knight to F3 and
surprisingly enough in this position
black has an excellent excellent move to
gain a material advantage it's not so
obvious again to see but it's a fun one
if you can spot it
so black to move and gain some material
advantage
uh see c4b here
D4 okay what's your idea with Knight to
D4
okay so we notice there's a discovery
right if they uh if we move our Knight
um there's some Discovery stuff going on
and if they recapped with the pawn we
can check and win back the bishop okay
what if they take with the Knight
or Knight takes
mm-hmm
so you're close but remember in this
variation this Pawn is still here
so we actually
right
uh yeah okay I see yeah we could take
with the pawn here and probably takes
and takes and I'm not sure we've gained
a material Edge
but you're really close to the idea the
instead of taking on D4 we want to take
here on E5
and we're going to do the same thing but
the key difference is with this move
we're actually defending our Bishop so
another way we could look at this is
here uh probably the biggest problem
with this line is you can just take the
bishop first
and now we're now we're actually in down
material
uh and if they take with the Knight then
yeah we can make it even but
but yeah so a nice kind of little tactic
to get some material back our Knight
defends the bishop so if they take it we
take back but if they take our Knight
with the pawn or the Knight now because
it's also on E5 the knight's not going
to be defending this bishop so we can
just win it
all right uh another concept to think
about with material advantages and
disadvantages is that your game plan
should really change based on the
material so if you are ahead in material
often you're going to want to look to
simplify a position or even go for
liquidation and we'll look at what that
means in a moment if you are down in
material generally you want to keep
stuff on the board you don't want to
make a lot of Trades you can trade pawns
but
you don't usually want to make a lot of
Trades and the reasoning is well it's
kind of the math right once you both run
out of a bunch of pieces
then it's going to be easier for the
type that has some stuff left so in this
position it's white to move and we're up
a good amount we have two Rooks and
black only has one but black has two
very Advanced pass pawns so this is
maybe a somewhat complicated position
but we can simplify it as white so
there's a lot of ways to win this game
but I think there's one that's just very
very simple and efficient that would be
kind of a smart one to try so take a
look at this position and thinking of
our material advantage what strategy can
we employ to make this much simpler so
we don't have to stress as much about
the position
okay check on D7 the Kings kind of move
and it cannot move forward and it cannot
stay in its row so it's going to go
somewhere let's say it goes to f8 yeah
yes so I really like this idea right we
have this forcing way where the biggest
problem for us in this position maybe
these past pawns are a bit of an
annoyance but really it's the fact that
black still has this Rook alive if we
can get rid of that Rook our life is a
lot easier even if it's not by winning
it just by trading it so playing Rook to
D7 forcing the king back
and then Rook today right we could win a
pawn here but the pawn is not really the
most important thing the important thing
is getting this work off the board
uh so something like this forcing a
trade and now we can just play some move
you know maybe Rook over here or
something and
with one Rook versus these pawns
obviously if you're a beginner you might
still struggle a little with this
position because end games are
notoriously complicated but you have a
better shot when you're not also
fighting against them with a rook right
they're going to be dealing with you on
your terms not the other way around
uh similarly oh yeah go ahead
so right now
once and we can try to use a roof to get
points on fmg I mean
for example they are taking their Pawn
on uh something like that yeah for
example like probably go with the Rook
to A2 or A3 yeah so the the question is
just kind of what strategy should we
employ for this end game for me I think
that would be fine if you take here in
my mind I like to say like what is the
what are the problems for me in an end
game so in this position I'm not
actually concerned about these pawns
because as long as my king is over here
like if you don't get your king down
here there's never a thread of promotion
right even if I move my king then if you
push I just take so I The Rook I'm just
we're putting here because I needed to
get it out of Harm's Way from The King
and I can make a threat if you take this
Pawn I'm probably just going to take you
back and again say okay it's your move
what are you doing and my goal here I
might not even try and like keep these
ones alive like if I do that's great but
my number one priority is just how can I
get your threats off the board and keep
my Rook alive because if I do that then
I can win with the king and the Rook or
maybe if I save one Pawn I can promote
and do a ladder mate so you have
different ideas but the first thing I
look for is what are the problems we're
actually issues for me and how do I not
lose from them it's a good question
our final consideration with material
although again remember these are all
interrelated
is uh the idea of liquidation
and this is even maybe a sacrificial one
so liquidation is not just how do we
simplify and make the position easier to
understand but how can we just get rid
of all the complexity how do we just
make it as simple as possible in this
case there's a lot of different ways to
do it right very similar to last time we
have our double Brooks like black has
theirs and I would say in this position
a really interesting idea you could go
for maybe it's not objectively I mean
it's definitely not objectively the best
but a really interesting idea is to do
the same thing we did before Rook to D7
and notice that this time when the king
steps in closer to us probably hear the
best move is just something like Rook to
H7 and you can double up but one
interesting thing I wanted to show is
you could even really consider making a
move like Rook to D to d8 forcing a
trade we are sacrificing both of our
Rooks just to get one of blacks but by
getting it off the board we now only
have two threats
right something like this and this Pawn
can never get past our King
these are more than enough pawns to win
in the end there's just nothing that
black can do it's uh if you know your
end games again maybe if you don't know
them I wouldn't recommend going for a
sacrifice like this but sometimes it can
be good strategy once you get
comfortable with some different
positions to make life easier on
yourself and give us some of that
material
okay we have about 10 minutes so we're
definitely not going to get to
everything I had but I want to at least
look at uh kind of the third thing so
first was King safety second material
and considering how these can be
advantages and disadvantages for us and
how we want to look at them and make
plans the third one is peace activity
peace activity basically means we're
going to try and find ways to place our
pieces on good squares where they
control a lot of the board you can also
think about this sort of like Mobility
where my pieces are able to go directly
affects how good they are
and greater Mobility leads to Greater
choices so one just absolutely classic
example is the Opera game we're not
going to spend a lot of time analyzing
it in depth but I think just a few key
moments really stick out because good
piece placement is one of the
fundamental ideas of this game that
leads Paul morphy to play just this
beautiful game it leads to a successful
attack on the king and sets up lots of
tactical opportunities to win material
because his pieces are coordinated so
let's just quickly take a look E4 E5
Knight to F3 attacking the pawn D6
defending D4 adding two attackers to
this Pawn
and white or sorry black plays Bishop G4
pinning the Knight removing one of the
attackers
Pawn takes Bishop takes Queen takes
pontics
everything is even
here white goes Bishop to C4
and white is saying my pieces are more
active I can develop with threats this
kind of relates to Tempo but you don't
have a lot of time to deal with my
threats or do make your own plans
because you have to spend all your time
responding right in this position we
have a Checkmate fret
so black played the move Knight to F6
and white continues Queen to B3 renewing
the threat
in this case it's not a Checkmate threat
but it's a threat of capturing on F7 and
there's also a fork here the queen also
attacks B7
and this is a really important moment in
the game
his opponent plays this move Queen to E7
which is a bit of a tricky move
the idea is it's defending this Rook
because the thread is not just the pawn
but also how do you save the rook and
it's indirectly doing so
and Paul morphy decides I'm not going to
grab this Pawn
we're going to talk about Pawn grabbing
uh in the next example as well but in
this example what Paul morphe could do
so he could take this Pawn
and now the only way for black to save
The Rook is to use the fact that the
queen and Bishop are lined up to call
check
forcing the queen to come back and take
and something like this maybe push maybe
block something
but morphe would still be up a pawn
in his mind that wasn't enough right he
has pieces that are active and doing a
lot so instead of just grabbing upon it
knowing that he's gonna be ahead and the
Queens are going to be off the board uh
we can't do Bishop takes F7 here because
the queen now defends that was the point
of Queen to E7
but Paul Murphy says instead of doing
that I'm going to notice that my pieces
are doing a lot and your pieces are set
up for one trick
but if you don't get to do that trick
then now your Bishop is stuck you've
made your Bishop worse and your queen is
just in the way
so morphe plays a really mature move
Knight to C3 just developing getting his
pieces more active more control in the
center
um
okay well uh his opponents didn't want
to lose the spawn so they placed C6 and
notice this is also a little bit of a
concession the queen now defends but
there's another problem with peace
activity now this Knight is having a
harder time getting out
and this is going to start to compound
right black or white plays a very
natural move Bishop to G5 further
limiting the mobility of his opponent's
pieces if we look at the board now this
Knight can't move because the queen
hangs this bishop can't move because of
the queen this Rook can't really move
because of the bishop like all of these
pieces are just congested
in order to try and gain some space and
some time and some kind of attack Paul
Murphy's opponents play the move B5 and
in another brilliant moment morphe
realizes that he can afford to give up
some material because his opponent's
pieces are so inactive he plays Knight
takes B5 sacrificing the Knight for two
Pawns in order to fully expose again
remember the king king safety expose his
opponent's king
Knight to D7
in morphe's calculation he is down one
point
but effectively his opponent if we look
at what pieces his opponent can use you
have the queen
and maybe have a little Rook but both of
these Knights are pinned this bishop is
stuck and this Rook cannot move
effectively like it's not really helpful
for it to go to G8
so really morphe is up just all of this
material because his opponent is able to
use it this is what I would call a
short-term Advantage right in the long
term if black is able to untangle here
they'll be better but given the current
position they're going to have to earn
that and Paul Murphy is not going to let
them
he Queen side castles to put even more
pressure on this piece
black defends
and now once again noticing just how he
can afford to abuse his peace activity
he sacrifices The Rook you can't take
with the Knight because again you lose
the queen so he takes with the rook and
it's not really a sacrifice because we
can always win it back
but another brilliancy instead of just
taking it right away he plays his other
Rook to D1 and his by doing a little bit
of simplification which is so weird
because he's behind but he's treating
this position like he's ahead because he
knows these two pieces are just not able
to do anything so he's really
simplifying which piece is black can use
and giving himself more pieces to use
that his opponent doesn't have
in order to try and untangle this black
place and move Queen to E6 hoping for a
trade hoping to open up the bishop and
morphe sees he has a beautiful
opportunity to end this game because of
how coordinated his pieces are
he plays Bishop takes D7 check
if the queen takes then The Rook takes
possibly or maybe there's a check so
instead he takes with the Knight another
reason he moved the queen to unpin it
but now there is Queen to B8 check
sacrificing the queen because of how
coordinated his pieces are
Checkmate one of the most beautiful
games ever played and really instructive
in terms of value and peace activity
over material sometimes right
understanding that how we can play to
our strengths and advantages in certain
positions
to farther that theme
already seen in this game of not
grabbing the pawn right morphe deciding
having one extra Pawn is not as much of
an advantage as seeing my opponent's
pieces all tied down
um
is what was worthwhile to him a quick
question was at the end was this queen
sacrifice deflecting the night
um I believe this would be a deflection
we're pulling a piece away in order to
like open up
I believe it would be deflection but to
look at that example of Pawn grabbing
Pawn grabbing is basically whenever a
player has an opportunity to capture a
pawn that's not really like part of the
main battle right like if someone is
castled and you have a chance to take
one of their Pawns in front of their
king that's not really poly grabbing
you're just exposing their King and
giving yourself chances for more
advantages but
if you enter some given position
this is part of the Pierce defense
and in this position
white has a choice right the material is
equal don't worry so much about how we
got it to this position but
um Black's last move after being
attacked by the bishop is to play Queen
to B4 and attacks this Pawn
and why should ask themselves is that
pawn actually a threat like are you
really gonna take that pawn and
truthfully I think the right answer is
no white should ignore this and just
Castle because if I get greedy and try
and grab this Pawn that's not really
involved notice I'm wasting time moving
my Queen instead of getting my other
pieces active and developed and that can
lead to some really big problems if
black is to take this Pawn
then there's a really nice move
now Chester I know this is I play this
for black so I know I know this is uh uh
not exactly upon grabbing there's more
Nuance to it than that but it's a really
interesting line and I think it's good
illustration for the dangers black can
face when you go for something like some
extra material here
uh should white play a move like Knight
to B5 we can already see some of the
problems because we've not really
developed right now there's a thread of
just trapping our Rook
there's also a threat of trying to get
our Queen somehow right our Queen is now
potentially a big Target
so say we play something like if we just
try and like move our Knight out of the
way
I believe our Queen is lost now to a
move
maybe just like rook and Rook but the
the queen is in a lot of danger
um so probably better is to do something
like Knight to E8 to defend
E5 trying to shut down our ability for
our Queen and Bishop to interact and
giving less space for our Queen
and now you have to start running away
because now like this this is
threatening to win the queen there's
just a lot of danger so you have to
start really running away and most of
the time your opponent is going to be
able to win the material back maybe a
more concrete example that'll be a
little easier to understand is the
poisoned Pawn because Pond grabbing is
more like a risky Venture like this
isn't really so involved I'm gonna get a
pawn but maybe I'm going to suffer a
little bit uh at times this can get so
bad as to lead to a significant
disadvantage and so this is really what
you want to watch out for the example is
going to be very similar
and notice in a lot of these there's a
queen that's going to come to the B file
it's just because it's like kind of a
natural Square
for the queen to come to if the C Pawn
is moved or if the queen like in the in
the Opera House game the queen went like
this and it's natural to attack this
Pawn if the bishop is not there right
once this bishop has relocated the pawn
is open and so in this position I think
the like main move for white is to just
play Queen to D2 and continue to
activate their pieces and give up this
Pawn
but kind of a funny one that illustrates
this very well is A3
because it cuts off an escape for the
queen if black were to go a little Pawn
grabbing right now then actually the
move Knight to A4 traps the queen
every piece is defended every square is
defended there is nowhere the queen can
safely run
very sad
indeed if you go here the pawn if you go
here they have the knights covering
these two the queen is just fully
trapped so you want to be a little
careful about that
all right given that we are about out of
time some final thoughts on peace
activity and then just kind of a general
conclusion
whenever you're in a given position and
you're trying to pick what should I do
right say you're like not in a super
sharp tactical position sometimes you
might even be in one of those and you
should still exhaust your forcing moves
and make sure everything checks out
there's no tactics for you or your
opponent but something else really
important just generally for selecting
your move is to look at which pieces of
yours are more passive right which ones
aren't doing so much maybe they're not
developed at all or maybe they were
developed once but now the position has
changed and they're not so helpful find
ways to relocate them look at ways to
get your Rooks onto open files or your
Bishops onto long diagonals or find key
targets like weaknesses in your
opponent's Pawn structure and attack
them finally peace activity has an
advantage or disadvantage is more
critical in open positions right think
of the Opera game here where some of
these pawns are like there's this big
open file traded off and the early parts
of the game
and then morphe opens it up more with
the sacrifice just makes the king such a
big Target right all of this area is
exposed
so in open positions where there's not
as many pawns blocking peace activity
becomes more important enclosed it's
less because it takes more time to Jump
Around
that is all the time we have tonight
thank you so much for joining hopefully
this has been helpful of thinking of
ways to evaluate positions that include
the material count but also go beyond
them especially looking at King safety
so important and peace activity please
stick around if you're interested our
class after this with our grand master
in Residence JJ Ali marandi we're super
excited to have him and he'll be
teaching grandmaster's choice so please
stick around and this has been beginner
breakdown look forward to seeing you
next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign